ciao ragazzi sono un po teso per fare
questo video perché è da inizio anno che
è successa una cosa nella mia vita non
ti mia ricercarsi sconvolto ancora provo
imbarazzo a parlare in pubblico di
quello che si pensi soprattutto di
quello che provo neanche una cosa che un
po imparato qui su youtube che non
sempre bisogna sentirsi pronti per
esserlo lasciatemi spiegare
sin da quando sono piccolo la mattina mi
capita di aprire gli occhi e per prima
cosa
ok non lo è come seconda cosa penso
ok non penso la mattina non c'è giorno
in cui io non mi svegli con qualcosa
dentro di me io voglio restituire alle
persone alla terra a 33 anni sono ormai
tante le cose alle quali bisogna saper
rinunciare
guardandomi indietro non mi pento
assolutamente delle scelte che ho fatto
anche se per colpa di queste sempre meno
persone mi stanno vicino il coraggio e
lo rendi tato da mio nonno essendo una
persona estremamente creativa sente
bisogno di vivere in un ambiente
ordinato pulito ma sopra ogni altra cosa
e igienizzato e dopo mariconda ho
brevettato il mio nuovo metodo per
punire la casa quando ma ricordo creo
una palla di tessuti che ha schiaccio
dentro l'armadio senza un ordine preciso
ma sono anche estremamente insicuro e
spesso mi trovo davanti lo specchio a
pensare che loro ho bisogno di lavorare
su me stesso per raggiungere importanti
obiettivi forse delle tappe nel reso
particolarmente sensibile al freddo ecco
perché metto sempre un paio di calzini
in più così
vengo spesso pervaso da un languore e
quella che prima era la mia colazione
tipo che è stata sostituita ho cambiato
gusti più succosi cautelare gira con
vitamina c e gli animali questo
accarezzando il mio gatto nega loro mi
fanno sorridere verticalmente il
vincitore per il premio puzza salsicce
senza utilizzare le mani muro da paris
che riuscita sbucciarle e il suo ds il
suo patrigno no moglie improvvisa di
fare del sasso conti josh vieni qui il
papa ti aspetta
scherza ragazze iscrivetevi intanto a
questo canale adesso dimostra subito il
tutorial per nulla rischia in contenuto
calo visto tra essi ha infatti lo
mettono un plauso riceve il pallone 2000
si smarcano sardi prof
finta su brancher ha lasciato a supporto
come un granchio alla guida virus
davanti al portiere vero che l'aiutava
do un tempo non c'era nulla che
sfuggisse al mio occhio di aquila ora mi
pare di indossare un paio di occhiali da
vista che mi fanno vedere tutto il
moscato allora niente gestibile guarda
bene a londra illustravamo veres di
celare addosso il sentono detto nemmeno
diamo il vento cicciolina dove c'erano
prima
adesso non ci sono più dignità quando
qualcuno si apre con me cerca conforto e
motivo spesso toccabile particolari con
the sonore che il mio orecchio non
riesce a recepire tipo adesso mio cugino
mi stava parlando di qualcosa di
importantissimo ma non riesco a capire
che cazzo sta dicendo o no una domanda
sì per bene il taglio bello e gli
strumenti di carpenteria mi regalano
forti emozioni voglia di spirito ora non
hanno riprovato la casa brucia cda un
effetto speciale
ok e poi si sa noi dovremmo essere
esterna cui tutti quanti sensibili
almeno questo tipo
un gesto così cazzo devi e niente c'è
stavano intorno in quella porta la mia
salute è diventata sempre più
cagionevole ormai bastano pochi gradi di
temperatura per spostarle direzione temi
la mano pesante ma li 77 due nomi devono
divenire pronto mi sente pronto ma senti
sta facendo la fine di jack jack del
titanic che jack skeleton no jack
non la carta o spesso bisogno di
conforto
le mie dita col passare degli anni sono
diventate sempre più pesanti quei
politici quanto pesano i pollici quindi
cerco di trovare metodi per rendere la
mia comunicazione più veloce ed è per
questo che a distanza di tre anni da un
video molto importante che ho fatto mi
lasciavo indiscrezione su quelle vederlo
continua a confermare ogni singola
parola di quello che ho detto voi potrà
pensare che questo sia un video
all'interno del quale io volevo
semplicemente fare un pesce d'aprile
immagino già durante il video ci saranno
stati qua sotto nei commenti pesce
d'aprile se non li avete scritti vi
pregherei di scrivere pesci e con lei
d'aprile per favore questo video nasce
da un pensiero che io ho sempre fatto
mio di con qualche modo parlare un
interesse non comporta automaticamente
un altro tipo di interesse si può amare
il calcio ed essere gay si può amare la
moda ed essere etero so che per molti
voi sarà una cosa assolutamente lampante
ma fidati che nel mondo ci conta gente
imbecille
magari condividiamo con loro questo
video no come il calcio con la continua
fa cagare
in realtà anche un po la moda concepisco
un cazzo ora scusate devo andare a
succhiare un pesce